et puis en seine saint denis on a choisi
de faire un bond dans le temps
pendant ces journées du patrimoine un
site archéologique qui est étudiée
depuis trois ans ouvre ses portes et
redonne vie un village gaulois
le nom du site ne s'invente pas la vache
à l'aise fernando malverde norbert cohen
se sont senti très à l'aise en marchant
sur les traces de nos ancêtres les
gaulois
clin d'oeil de l'histoire c'est à deux
pas du quartier de bobigny où rené
goscinny a vécu inventait astérix qu'un
village gaulois a été découvert il ya
cinq ans le site archéologique de la
vache à l'aise au coeur d'une zac ouvre
ses portes au public tout le week end
dans le cadre des journées du patrimoine
les archéologues ont troqué les outils
de fouille pour se transformer en guide
à auch la paille en fait la céramique
tournée gallo-romaine et tracy en
fonction des en découvrant grandeur
nature la construction d'une maison
gauloise l'allumage d'un feu ou le
fonctionnement des fours à pain les
visiteurs ont l'impression d'approcher
concrètement la vie quotidienne de nos
lointains ancêtres une pédagogie très
vivante adapté à tous les âges
on peut faire du feu avec du silex du
ferréol est un champignon qui s'appelle
l'amadouer j'applique et comment on
fabriquer les maisons commun les gaulois
est ce votre foi on a vu aussi comment
il pouvait savoir si les gaulois étaient
riches la curiosité du public est
évidente d'où l'idée d'un rêve certains
d'un site archéologique préservé avec la
construction d'un village gaulois
permanent ce type de vestiges n'est pas
qu'on construit en pierre ou en bois
sont des vestiges fugace et en réalité
lorsque la fouille est achevée
finalement il subsiste qu'un terrain
naturel plus ou moins percée de trancher
deux trous de poteaux donc en fait il
reste pas grand-chose à conserver in
situ et l'idéal c'est de s'engager vers
des opérations de reconstruction
finalement les enfants de banlieue n'ont
pas tous comme ancêtres les gaulois mais
la transmission du passé des
connaissances est une richesse qu'il
connaît pas de frontières et sachez que
si vous souhaitez visiter ce site et
faire du foeil des silex par exemple il
crée encore ouvert au public le week-end
prochain
une deuxième chance pour les passionnés
des gaulois